how does cyberpunk 2077 on the base ps4
stack up compared to it running on the
ps5
well as we'll see in this video not
great
just to clarify a few things what's
running on the ps5 is the ps4 version of
the game
not the upgraded ps5 version which comes
out sometime
next year also both versions have the
latest patch as of the release of this
video
enjoy
hey everyone feels great to have you
back
so then did you all hear about that
arasaka aircraft carrier docked in night
city
called kujira or the whale
apparently the court figured it wasn't
safe in japanese waters
afraid some local fishermen might
harpoon it for scientific research
but honestly it's quite the power move
wonder what militech will respond with
maybe meyers will fly a rust bucket b-17
flying fortress over arasaka hq
oh man that's that is insensitive
i am so sorry where are my manners
president
myers i mean of course gotta respect the
office
anyhoo
that'll make you any less part of this
squad squad
charming
bug could at least try to be nice
you want nice supportive call the damn
helpline
[Music]
keep her steady
[Music]
for the driver
don't forget
hey regina jones here if you're looking
for work at watson
give me a call i said something about a
surprise yesterday
am i remembering right or just had a
brain clock
probably both because you usually forget
[ __ ]
but it just so happens i think i might
have bagged us
as sweet as j.o.b
go on i mean maybe it's not as big as
that but
just that he's fronted by a little known
someone named dexter deshawn
totally the top fixer in night [ __ ]
city
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this is it come on v find me once
vic's done dusting your circuits
we'll high
[Music]
dr vector will see you now
[Music]
i got a classic tail for you psycho gang
doing his thing two weeks back
jumped her militech convoy got away with
the gear
corp don't even know maelstrom's
involved
now see convoy was carrying the flathead
a
little combat bot a prototype and i need
me that bit of high grade military again
cause if we don't get that body we don't
get no soccer chill
and we sure as hell don't get no happily
ever after
but don't get excited it's a single-use
toy
now i slide out purchase the damn thing
from maelstrom
problem is i did so from a gentleman by
the name of brick
i say win cause brick was the leader
three days after we'd sealed our deal
his friend and gang mate one simon
randle aka royce
playing dropped his ass royce is in
charge now
and i got no way of knowing if he aims
to honor his predecessor's word
to add to this [ __ ] from one meredith
style of militech has developed an
interest in said convoy
[Music]
mr prima donna corporal agent internal
affairs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
anyone here hello
three
you